حفظها في البدايه بدات بتحفيز القران
في هناك رجال دين
يحفظون القران او يحفظون معظم القران
تعاونوا تتكاتفوا بحيث انه استحضروا
القران شفهيا
من
الغلاف للغلاف
تولوا طبعا من ضمن
خلينا نقول فعل الخير بالنسبه لهم
تحفيز القران للشباب وللي لا يحفظ القران
وهذا كان يعني خليني نقول سنه قوي جدا
للمتدينين يعني اطراف الحركه الدينيه ان
يتلو القران عزاء عزاء للنفس
يقويهم يقويهم يقويهم من الداخل فكان هذه
الحفظه هنا كانوا يحفظوا القران لو حضرتك
كنت تحفظ ايضا او يعني بالمعيه يعني او
صديقك المفضل
مع صديقي ما سالته عن الناحيه يعني هو
المسيحي بس يعني اذا كان هذا بس حفظ يعني
صار يعرف كثير وبفهم كثير بموضوع الدين
الاسلامي واحكام الدين الاسلامي والشريعه
الاسلاميه
يعني سنوات طويله جدا
وحواليه يعني تتكرر المواضيع بس بالنسبه
للحفظ ليس فقط القران ايضا طور الامر
صاروا يحفظه
معلومات
في البدايه حفظه اسماء
اللي ذهبوا للاعدام
اللي بده يروح على الاعدام في دفع مثلا
المهجر بده يروح ثمانيه اعدام
بيحفظوهن معلوماتهم وعنوان
اللي بقيانين احياء يعني
وبيكرروا وبيحفظوا يعني انه فلان الفلاني
مدينه كذا
بيت وكذا عنوان وكذا بالمستقبل فيما لو
حدثوا انه طلع احد الحفظه الى
خارج سنه تم اخلاء سبيله او الافراج عنه
هو المفروض يروح يبلغ اهالي الناس هدول
انه مصير ابنائبكم كان كذا كذا كذا تم
اعدامه بتاريخ بتاريخ كذا بعدين
حكينا عنها قبل شوي دقيقه
تفتح له مجال الكلام يعني